warning this video contains attack on
titan season one spoilers but there are
no manga spoilers so if you only seen
the anime you're still good what is up
everybody it's adamak here for anime
uproar and since we got such great
feedback from you guys on our code geass
news video we decided to do on
everything we know so far video for
attack on titan season two as well here
on this channel we want to be your go-to
place for the latest news on all the
huge releases coming out in 2017
including code geass season 3 attack on
titan season 2 one punch man season two
and seven deadly sins season two if you
want to be the first to know when all
the latest news comes out be sure to
subscribe and make sure that you hit
that notification belt because as soon
as we get new news we're going to be
doing live streams we're going to be
making videos so we definitely want you
to be a part of that and if you want to
be in touch with us on a daily basis
feel free to join our discord server the
link is in the description and feel free
to follow us on social media so we
already know that attack on titan season
2 is going to feature more traitors and
conspiracies new types of titans and
also new Titan shapeshifters we also
know from this promotional image that
was posted on the official Japanese
Twitter for attack on titan that in
season two Titan Aaron is going to be
facing off against armored titan and
colossal titan once again and i just
want to remind you guys that there will
be no manga spoilers in this video at
least not intentionally i personally
haven't read the manga yet i've only
seen the anime and i'm only looking at
news about season two of the anime in
particular it is now officially
confirmed that attack on titan season
two will begin airing in april 2017 and
it has been officially licensed by
Funimation a brand new trailer for
season two was also released back on
christmas day of 2016 and the trailer
featured a whole bunch of hints and
clues about what is going to happen in
season two now you might remember that
at the very end of the final episode of
attack on titan season one we see a
piece of all Cena crumble and the face
of a titan is revealed to be inside this
crazy revelation at the very end of the
episode led many to speculate that there
might be many more titans located within
the walls and one theory for why they
might be there is that Titans have that
unique power to harden their bodies to
make them harder than
stone itself so in order for the wall to
be strong enough to stand up to tighten
attacks the best way to protect it I
suppose could be to include hardened
Titans in inside the wall as the
foundation of the wall in order to keep
other Titans out in this preview clip
which was leaked online about a year ago
the story seems to pick up from the
ending of the last season with the
survey Corp deciding to investigate what
was happening with the Titans face only
to be warned by one of the village
elders who is referred to as pastor nick
to quickly seal up the gaping hole
before sunlight hits the titan while the
trailer doesn't explain this the
statement clearly indicates that the
titan is inactive or in a vegetative
state while inside the wall but this
also implies that perhaps the titan
could awaken or come back to life if he
is hit by sunlight because we know that
most Titans need sunlight to survive if
you want to see this full preview clip
the link is in the description so feel
free to check it out and also if you
want to see the full new trailer which
just came out in December you can also
find that in the description the new
trailer definitely gives us a whole
bottle Clues including the fact that
humanity is once again under major
attack by Titans and in danger of being
extinct that brand new types of titans
are going to be showing up in season two
like this Titan that looks like a
Sasquatch or something and in the actual
trailer he is identified as beast
tighten the trailer also shows us
certain Titans other than Aaron who also
appear to be fighting against their
fellow Titans and the trailer implies
that they are tightened out there who
have been fighting to protect humanity
this whole time which also makes us
think if perhaps these Titans are also
shapeshifters like Aaron who live
amongst the humans but actually use
their Titan powers to fight against the
other Titans on top of that a number of
characters in the trailer mentioned
conspiracies and traders and is it just
me or does this guy right here look a
lot like Victor from Yuri oh nice Yuri a
nice Illuminati confirmed as far as the
manga goes judging from the trailer many
are speculating that the new season is
going to combine two arcs from the manga
the uprising arc and the clash of titans
arc and many are also speculating that
we are going to learn a lot more about
the history of the walls in the second
season so yeah this is all really
exciting news I personally can't wait
I've been waiting for years for season
two after i saw season one when it first
came out but we also have some not so
exciting news on the attack of titan
front a few days ago we learned that
junction park the first editor of the
attack on titan manga was actually
arrested for the murder of his wife the
former editor who is 41 years old was
taken into custody by the Tokyo
Metropolitan Police for allegedly
committing the murder of his 38 year old
wife his wife was found that in August
of last year and the investigation had
been ongoing ever since so while that
piece of news is obviously tragic and
horrible on the manga front we do have
some good news as far as the attack on
Titan season 2 is concerned even though
most manga or manga creators are not
directly involved with the anime
adaptations of their work we know that
attack on Titan manga creator Hajime
isayama has confirmed last year that he
has been directly involved in working on
the screen writing process for attack on
Titan season 2 e syama said that he was
in fact directly involved with the
screen writing process for season 2 and
he also implied that he was happy with
the way things were turning out which is
obviously great news for all the manga
fans who want to make sure that the
anime stays loyal to the source material
and that's everything we know so far
about attack on Titan season 2 without
going into all the manga spoilers of
course if you want to stay up to date on
all the latest news be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and also
be sure to join us in the discord server
the link is in the description if you
want to stay in touch with us on a day
to day basis once again thanks so much
guys for all the support you've been
giving us lately the channel has been
growing at an amazing rate and it's all
thanks to you we really appreciate it
and until next time see ya space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]